I've had that fomo of fallen into the
comparison pitfalls of that's the worst
comparing is the worst it is and and
that is also I think something that's
really like not to say that there isn't
anyone who in various other Industries
but I would imagine it's pretty
heightened in the film and
television uh anyone who's an actor is
definitely felt that way and it's really
hard to stay in your own lane you know
and like it's like for it's stuck with
me but I always think of it um some like
I don't know where I read or saw this
but the idea of like you know if you're
a swimmer and you're swimming in your
lane if you constantly are just looking
over what everyone else is doing and
what their time is you're just slowing
yourself down hang on though see in my
mind I'm like oh I got to pick it
up that guy's beating me I got to get to
that Finish Line before that dude that's
funny no it slows me down